[Music]
this is festival food Lee's where we go
to fairs across the country and try
three things a fan favorite a hidden gem
and a wacky snack then pick our favorite
this week or at the fuse night market
let's dig in
[Music]
I'm AJ and I'm Alli and this is festival
foodies today we're at the queen's night
market what makes the queen's night
market so special is the mix of cultures
here it has foods from over 20 different
countries I'm so excited for this one
look out so the Queen's night market
started back in 2015 you know our
mission is to represent as many
countries as possible with our food over
the last three and a half years we've
had over 300 different food vendors and
represented over 80 countries I think
first and foremost to us it's a cultural
event it's community space but obviously
people come to the food first up is the
fan favorite we're at the Malaysian
project where they serve a signature
Malaysian burger wrapped in an omelette
I saw this thing online about a year ago
and I've been dying to try it it's a
very normal food for us back home every
time you see a I think people really
like it with a different not to say we
are the first to do this kind of burger
up but so far in Queens I think we had
only one s4
we have the process of having the
homeland first we flatten the homeland
and we put a bit carry in the middle and
also homemade a spicy mayo on top as my
wife
it's just perfect and I've never had egg
in a burger before a whole lot of
different flavors like kind of playing
together it's really really good
it's not looking like yours doesn't look
like is slowly gentle slowly gentle and
I love the curry seasoning it beautiful
wow that's looking good and it's like a
little egg burger package that we're
gonna send in the moons in my mouth I'm
really proud of us these look good yeah
well I think we did a good job for being
novices Cheers it I like it cuz it's
double protein you've got the burger
patty and then the egg enveloping it
which I really love
yeah it's unlike any other burger I've
ever eaten and I've eaten a lot of
burgers next it's time for a hidden gem
you become the Queen's night market for
a lot of different things but what they
don't know about are these delicious
meal cakes I'm really excited to try
them we'll kick this is that traditional
Taiwanese Street food in a lot of night
market in Taiwan and Chinese people
enjoy eating there since they were a kid
so being in Quincy Market we thought
it's a perfect place for us to sell this
since we make it on-site it's really
fresh we we use our high quality
ingredients and also the taste of the
cakes are really consistent each time so
people will love it it's a little chilly
out of here and these are super warm so
we're really excited I think I'm gonna
go watch or read the abdu or the
chocolate banana Cheers stood out my
friend
[Music]
this is bursting with red beans this
chocolate is so super rich
I love how warm it is in the center it's
like warm gooey
[Music]
so far so yummy I think that means it's
time for our wacky snack last but not
least wacky snack
Sam's right ice cream is a New York
festival favorite and I cannot wait to
try it
so fries cream is pretty much like a
cover of batter and then we coat it with
like different crusts bread crumb is a
classic cornflake crust Oreo crust and
red velvet crust
people look for a center ice cream so
much because it's different from other
places is extra crunchy and then the ice
cream is still cold inside it's not
soggy Queensland market we normally sell
average of 400 plus the best night we
had was the grand opening of the Queen's
night market which we have sold close to
a thousand order within six hours what
if not if you fried ice cream it would
still be cold
it's fried ice cream fried ice cream
[Music]
it's like a warm deep fried ice cream
sandwich I'm surprised about melting
faster I feel pricing Li civilized if
you like fried foods and you like sweets
this is the new funnel cake of the
center mmm I feel like we took a mini
tour around the world I know I ate so
many foods tonight that I've never had
before which one was your favorite he
hands down the Malaysian project food I
was good was just a mix of flavors I've
never had in a burner form ever before
and it was just so delicious so good I
think I liked the wheel cake that was
really good I've never seen anything
like that before and it was just so
sweet and like gooey in the center and I
wasn't expecting that so I loved it
that's often the Queen's night market
stay hungry
[Music]